we've already spent a couple of videos
talking about enzymes and what i want to
do in this video is dig a little bit
deeper and focus on some actors that
actually help enzymes and just as a
reminder enzymes are around to help
reactions to proceed to lower their
activation energies to make the the
reactions happen more frequently or to
happen faster now we've already seen
examples of enzymes and just to frame
things in our brain properly sometimes
in a textbook you'll see an enzyme like
this you'll see a drawing like this and
you'll say and people will call this
the enzyme
they'll call this the enzyme and then
they'll call
they'll call this right they'll say okay
and it's acting on some type of a
substrate right over here it's going to
do something to that and this is nice
for a very abstract textbook idea of a
substrate locking into an enzyme like
this but this isn't actually what it
looks like in a biological system we
have to remind ourselves when people
talk about enzymes they're talking about
proteins now there are these kind of rna
enzymes called ribozymes but the great
majority when we're talking about
enzymes we tend to be talking about
proteins and we spend a lot of time
talking about how proteins are these
structures there's polypeptides and all
the side chains of the various amino
acids fold the proteins in all sorts of
different ways so uh if i were a better
drawing for something like this you know
it would be this this protein it's all
folded in different ways maybe it has
some alpha helices here maybe it has
some beta sheets right over here it's
all this kind of crazy stuff right over
there and then the substrate might be
some type of a molecule that is it gets
embedded it gets embedded in the protein
and you see some examples right over
here this is actually a hexokinase model
and you see the at least you can see a
little bit of the atp right over there
and it's a little harder to see the
glucose that's going to be
phosphorylated and this reaction is
being facilitated by this big protein
structure the hexokinase now what we're
going to focus on in this video
is that when we talk about an enzyme
we're talking about proteins we're
talking about a chain of amino acids but
there's often other parts of the enzyme
that aren't officially proteins and we
even saw that when we talked about
hexokinases when we talked about the
phosphorylation of glucose we said hey
the rate the way that it lowers the
activation energy is you have these
positive magnesium ions these positive
magnesium ions that can keep the
electrons and the phosphate groups a
little bit busy draw them away so that
the so that this hydroxyl group right
over here can bond with this phosphate
and not be interfered with these
electrons well these these magnesium
ions right over here they aren't
officially part of the protein these are
what we call cofactors
so you might have a cofactor
right over there that gets that latches
on to the broader protein to become part
of the enzyme and you actually need that
for the reaction to proceed it plays a
crucial role here so another drawing in
the textbook you'll see something like
this or even you know they'll draw
they'll say okay in order for this
reaction to proceed yes you need the
substrate but you also need the cofactor
the cofactor and once again it sounds
like a fancy word but all it means is
the non-protein part of an enzyme it's
another molecule or or ion or atom that
is involved in letting the enzyme
perform its function that it's not
formally it's not formally in a part of
an amino acid or part of a
side chain or part of the protein but
it's another thing that needs to be
there to help catalyze the reaction we
saw that with hexokinase you had
magnesium ions that the the the that the
complex picks up and this is why you
know when people talk about your
vitamins and minerals a lot of the
vitamins and minerals that you need they
actually act as cofactors for
four enzymes and so you can even see it
in this drawing over here at least based
on
what i read these are the magnesium
ions in green right over here and these
are cofactors
these are cofactors so cofactor
non-protein part of your actual enzyme
now we can subdivide cofactors even more
we can divide them into organic
cofactors and non or inorganic cofactors
so if you have cofactors
you have cofactors we've seen an
inorganic cofactor a lot of these ions
you'll see magnesium ions you'll see
sodium ions you'll see calcium ions
you'll see all sorts of things acting as
cofactors oftentimes to distract
electrons so that or to keep them busy
so that electrons can proceed but you
can also have organic ones you can also
have organic
molecules remember organic molecules
these are just they'll involve carbon
they have chains of carbons and other
things and cofactors that are organic
organic molecules we call them coenzymes
coenzymes
and there's a bunch of examples of
coenzymes this right over here is the
enzyme lactate
dehydrogenase
and it has the coenzyme and this
coenzyme you are going to see a lot in
your biological careers and a
nad right over here notice this isn't
just an ion it is an entire molecule it
has carbon in it that's why we call it
organic and it is not formally protein
it's not it's not part of the the amino
acids that make up the protein so that's
what makes it a cofactor and since it's
since it's an entire organic molecule we
call this a coenzyme
co-coenzyme
but like any cofactor it plays a role in
actually allowing the enzyme to do its
function to facilitate reaction and this
particular coenzyme nad which you're
going to see a lot it helps facilitate
the transfer of hydride ions hydride
ions never or very seldom exist by
themselves but it's a hydrogen with an
extra electron so it has a negative
so it has a negative charge so it allows
to the transfer of this group
or from from a from a substrate or to a
substrate and that's because nad
nad can accept a hydride anion right
over here and become nadh and if you
want to see its broader structure it's
actually quite fascinating i'll probably
do a whole video on nad because uh in so
many textbooks growing up i just saw you
know nad and nadh and i'm like what is
this thing it's a fascinating molecule
so what it can do is it can actually
pick up the hydride anion right over
here at this carbon you can actually
form another bond with the hydrogen i'll
do that in a future video i'll show the
mechanism for it but it's a pretty cool
molecule and i like to actually look at
this molecule remember the whole focus
of this is coenzymes but we see these
patterns throughout biology because the
name
nicotinamide adenine dinucleotide
exactly describes what it is
nicotinamide
nicotinamide right down here that is
that is this piece
of the molecule and this is the part
that can accept a hydride or let go of a
hydride so you could say this is the
active part of the molecule
adenine our good old friends we've we've
seen adenine and dna and rna in atp so
this is our good old friend
adenine right over here and it says
dinucleotide because we actually have
two nucleotides paired together their
phosphate groups are tied together and
there's a couple cool ways to think
about this you have an adenine right
over here you have a ribose you have a
phosphate group if you just looked at
if you just looked at this piece
right over here
if you looked at this right over here
this is your building block this this is
your building block of r or this could
be a building block of rna if you have
an adenine right over there and if you
include
if you include let me undo this if you
include all of this
this right over here this is adp but the
reason why it's called dinucleotides you
can also divide it the other way you can
say all right you have one nucleotide
that has nicotinamide
right over here
so that's
one of the nucleotides and then the new
other nucleotide is right over here the
one that involves the one that involves
adenine and that's why it's called
dinucleotide so hopefully this makes nad
less of a mysterious molecule we'll see
it in the future but i i like to look at
it because it's it's got all these
patterns it's got all these components
that you see over and over again you see
an atp you see it in rna over and over
again but the this isn't the only this
isn't the only cofactor or coenzyme
there are many many others in fact when
people say take your vitamins and your
minerals that tends to be because they
are cofactors vitamin c is a very
important cofactor to be involved in
enzymes that well i won't go into all of
the different things that it can do
these are two different views of vitamin
c a space filling model and this is a
ball and stick model right over here
vitamin c folic acid once again two
different views but these are all
coenzymes they all work they all work
you know if you have a protein
right over here
that you know it's all this really
complex structure maybe you have some
substrates but to help facilitate let me
do the substrates in a different color
in a different color so maybe you have
some substrates so these are the things
that the enzymes trying to catalyze the
reactions for but then you could have
some ions which would you know you could
kind of view these as
you would view these
you would view the ions as
cofactors and you could have organic
cofactors like your the vitamin c or
other things that we talked about
that are also involved in help
facilitating the mechanism or help
facilitate the reaction and once again
sometimes it might be to help stabilize
some charge sometimes it might be to be
an electron acceptor or a donor or a
whole series of different things they
can they can actually act as part of the
reaction mechanism